I Define Myself by who I am not what I
do and I think one of the big challenges
that a lot of people face is they
intertwine their identity with their
work I am a lawyer I am a fitness coach
or whatever you know somebody wants to
do and then if you lose that job by your
choice or not your own choice I see a
lot of people have an identity crisis
because they no longer do the thing that
they did I don't mind what I do because
I get to be an optimist in everything
that I do the way I live my life is I
live completely focused with a vision
that is extremely far away I'll never
get there now I imagine a world in which
the vast majority of people wake up
every single morning inspired feel safe
wherever they are and the day fulfilled
by the work that they do and for me the
objective is to figure out all the ways
that I can
start moving closer and closer towards
that war